what works for the show in season eight
has loads of surprises glint was better
known for his role as your moment said
in a recent interview today I'm going to
talk about a theory of mind is
introduced with a long time ago it's an
unexpected fate of the most fearsome man
in Seven Kingdoms called the mountain
that rides or simply the mountain at his
point will expect the mountain to die
include gamble that will take place
after Gregor would strike down Jamie who
would prior kill Cersei many fans
however are wondering how Jaime even
managed to kill Cersei when the mountain
is guarding her of course the Jaime most
likely would not be able to pass by Sir
Gregor Clegane and let's face it he
would not stand a chance against the
mountain whose nearly death only made
him stronger
so yeah answer on your question about
how Jaime is going to pass by sources
moshus that guard is simply he will not
you might be confused now and you might
also moaner does that mean the Jameel
not kill Cersei after all well no it
doesn't I still believe that Jaime will
in the final episodes of season 8 kill
his once beloved sister and lover Cersei
all I'm saying is that a popular theory
of the mountain being killed including
ball after striking down Jaime most
likely will not come true even though
this theory in me Jaime kill Cersei the
mountain kills Jamie and the Hound kills
the mountain is the most popular theory
we should all take a moment and realize
that in the game eternal show the most
obvious tears often do not come true
therefore I created a fearing image the
mountain will betray Cersei on Qyburn
soldiers and will be the one to help
Jaime to put an end to the mad Queen the
mountains rolled by the story will be
helping Jamie to pass by Queen's Guard
and put an end to Cersei if this comes
true it would also confirm another tear
if mine in which Khyber has been working
for Varys this whole time as we all know
I never expressed to Tyrion just
expected from you to believe in it I
always state some kind of proof that
might confirm my theory that I mentioned
using you with I will read it brought
you a 10 minute long video in which I
provided your possible probes that are
going favor to this theory in which
Qyburn is this whole time working for
various the same goes for a theory in
which the mountain guy burns creation is
going to help Jamie on Kai MERS command
in this video I am only going to show
you the most trusted or should I say the
most obvious proofs along with a few
phasers supporting already mentioned
theories from the very beginning since
the very first episode Qyburn appeared
on show they're raising more and more
yet unexplained and unanswered questions
for example why did cry burning me
decide to stay the mountains life life
of the same man that almost killed him
at Harrenhal
stealing clothes sure native friends
lucky also housed Qyburn been able to
use my capabilities of same verse the
verse has used in previous seasons
similar birds that various Ontarians
concerns about their loyalty lo replied
with man can be fickle but bird sellers
trust
how's your mother sure your father no
one's seen him come back I don't think
so
you miss him he was nice he called us as
little birds
he gave us sweets it's funny you should
mention that that's what I happen to
find us today and now remember if any of
your friends like sweets will need help
they can always come to me all I need in
return tell me can you little birds get
a message to the good masters of us of
all the wise masters of yunkai
benevolent in flavours of volantis of
course men can be fickle but birds I
always trust we all know that words
cannot be fooled that easy additionally
Varys is known as a man of knowledge and
whispers as a man that knows every step
of every living man in Seven Kingdoms
if there's fully trust someone that
someone will not betray him even if that
would mean the death for that someone as
well no Qyburn sir she became extremely
close considering the [ __ ] are
situated people around her specially
just ride ones to paranoia and
suspicious thoughts
Qyburn however gains hers his full trust
will bring in stir Gregor cool game
makes life after he was seriously
wounded by spear coded in Manticore
venom during his fight against Oberyn
Martell the honor of presenting the
newest member of the Kingsguard
please your grace he has taken a holy
vow of silence
his phone that he will not speak until
all his Grace's enemies are dead after
death Cersei named Qyburn as master
whispers as the varices replacement on a
small Council even if Qyburn managed to
bribe a few versus little birds and even
if those few spice agreed to betray
berries there is no way that verse would
not find it out there's no way that none
of them would send whisper to Eris this
is also raising a few important
questions since you're probably
wondering if Qyburn and little birds are
loyal to words why the little birds
inform Qyburn about wildfire who later
informed Cersei about it
which led to annihilation of the great
Sept of Baelor along with all search his
enemies before I give you an answer on
that question let me just highlight one
fact that you all have to know before we
go any further
where's has been loyal to House
Targaryen all the time where's has been
working on a plan to bring to Danny and
House Targaryen back the Iron Throne
that has been taken from them since the
fall House Targaryen here we come to our
answer on a question which was if Qyburn
and little birds are loyal to very
sweaty little birds inform Qyburn about
wildfire cool a dream from Cersei the
answer and that question is actually
pretty simple
sir she's plan to destroy the great Sept
of Baelor along with all the important
people in it match perfectly with vs.
plan additionally my opinion where
sexual commanded Qyburn in his little
birds to find out if the Wildfire
julie's under the great Sept of Baelor
and if it's really is to inform Cersei
about it immediately Varys is a smart
man he was aware that if Sir she wipes
out most of the leadership at the
wildfire it would lead her to lose all
her allies which in fact exactly
happened and as Varys probably expected
it gave him an opportunity to make new
allies in this case with Olenna Tyrell
who now only wants to venture son her
nephew and her niece says she stole the
future from me she killed my son
she killed my grandson she killed my
granddaughter survival is not what I'm
after now you're absolutely right I
chose the wrong words it is not survival
I offered it is your heart's desire
and what is my heart's desire vengeance
justice
fire and blood by the sect where's
manage to provide a new life for his
screen and made a nurse's takeover even
easier also the fact that Qyburn brought
sir gregor clegane to life who back in
the third season almost killed him is
something that i can get over it would
only make sense if it's part of a bigger
plan of vengeance it could be that
Qyburn created a monster only to get
even closer to Cersei which would allow
them and the time comes the easily kill
Cersei all she thinks that he is her
most trusted protector as the mountain
was her closest in the only guard
through the past few seasons it's safe
to say that he will be in the final
season as well if the steering I'm sure
it would only prove once again how
brilliant mind overseas which would once
again confirm versus high intelligence
and cunning skills also this comes true
it would only confirm an old theory if
my name is Jaime is going to kill Cersei
with the mountains help it's most likely
true that we are going to see only few
scenes of sir Gregor could gain in the
upcoming season but those few could be
one of the most important scenes that
we're going to see might be the scenes
that will textures his reign to an early
end this represents arguably the
greatest taste in Game of Thrones show
even greater than Bolton's and phrase
betrayal over Starks Cersei would be
betrayed by her three most trusted
people would be killed by her brother by
her most trusted advisor and by her most
trusted guard not only that it would be
one of the greatest twists in the game
of Thrones show but it also seems like
something the showrunners would pull out
leave us the touch of speechless in
season finale however I still expected
gamble to eventually happen if a few of
us thought that month in with one codec
switch allowing Jaime to kill Cersei
would be is enough for his brother
sender to forgive him all his since
that's definitely not going to happen
sir Gregor Clegane has done more than a
few horrible things throughout his life
which he started doing since he was a
child he held his own brother's head
into burning breezier only because his
younger brother played with the toy that
he discarded as he was growing he was
killing more and more innocent people
was raiding more and more villages only
to later be knighted by prince rhaegar
targaryen this honorable man that
Montanez whom always liked honor only
one year passed since he was knighted by
Prince Rhaegar and still he obeyed
orders to kill the same princes two
children during Robert's rebellion upon
killing Reger's daughter and babies and
mountain and proceeded to brutal rape
rakers wife Elia weapon he killed her
the head of hospital gain is infamously
dishonorable man and even if he is going
to help Jaime he still deserves to die
and the best way to see the mountains
death would be including bowl